-You got some fans here.
-I see. Wow! This is crazy.
-And you got some fans here.
-Yes, me. I'm the number one.
-I mean -- Yeah.
Megan is the number-one fan.
I have not seen all of
"Stranger Things," so I'm --
-So why would you even
talk to him? Talk to me.
-Okay, okay.
-No spoilers.
-No spoilers. No spoilers.
-We're gonna spoil it. What?
Has everybody
in the crowd seen...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-The last two, yeah.
But you know what it is?
It's not like a show
is a half-hour
or something like that.
These are like movies.
-They are. They're very long.
Very jam-packed. So I get it.
-That's what I
appreciate about it,
because shows that are
30 minutes, I'm upset.
Like, I need you to make
this a production
the whole way through
so I can stay hooked.
-Right. We got the note.
We got the note.
-Exactly.
I understand what's happening.
Boom. Okay.
-This was not
your first big acting role.
Your first big acting role,
I want to remind you,
was in the
"Hannah Montana" movie.
[ Cheers and applause ]
There you are on the red carpet.
-Yes!
-On the red carpet.
-Yes, that was
my first red carpet.
And, obviously,
I dressed myself.
Thank you, Betsey Johnson,
at the Green Hills Mall.
-What year was this? 2009?
-Yeah, I was like 13 or 14,
I think.
-Yeah.
-And -- Oh, the shoes, yeah.
-And do you remember auditioning
and all that stuff and
getting cast?
-Yeah. I mean, it was --
So, I grew up in Nashville.
-Whoo!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, yeah, okay. Yeah.
-Tennessee.
-Yeah, so, it's not -- It wasn't
a huge film town at that time.
And then this -- You know,
this sort of major production
was rolling through.
It was a big deal.
Everyone was very excited.
And, yeah, they had these
two British, like, twin roles
that they decided to
cast locally.
And, somehow, I --
-They said, "We want a girl
from Nashville, Tennessee,
to be British."
-You played British.
-Yeah.
-It makes sense.
-Yeah, to my benefit,
maybe not theirs.
-Yeah. Well, we actually have
the clip of you
making your acting debut
in "Hannah Montana: The Movie."
-Yes!
-Watch this.
-Are we too late?
Is she going to sing again?
-I mean, I just
can't believe it.
[ Crowd chanting "Hannah!" ]
-Oh, my God!
It's Hannah Montana! Oh, my God!
You're right there!
I'm right here!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ British accent ]
It's Hannah Montana!
It's Hannah! Oh, my God!
You have to let us backstage.
[ Normal voice ] I could have
been your, like, brother.
-[ British accent ] Oh, my God.
It's Hannah Montana.
-Your older brother.
-Yeah, absolutely.
-[ British accent ] I brought
my little sister here to see
Hannah Montana.
-Hannah! Oh, my God!
-Oh, both of -- Yeah, okay,
all of us could have done it.
-We're the twins from England.
-The next one.
The next one, I think.
We'll find out what happens.
-Hopefully. Fingers crossed.
-Yeah.
-"Stranger Things,"
obviously, stratosphere.
I mean, honestly,
can you walk down the street
where people not scream,
"Nancy, Nancy"?
-Nancy! That would be me.
Oh, my God, Nancy.
-Yeah, it's a lot.
Yeah, it's kind of --
It never gets normal.
You know,
it's a really weird thing.
-Are you living,
like, in L.A. now?
-No, I live here.
I live here in New York.
So --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, I'll see you
on the street.
-I was going to
ask -- I was going to ask if
you're Team Jancy
or Team Stancy?
-I'm team Stancy.
-You are?
-What?
-I want Steve.
-Stancy.
-There's Jonathan,
and there's Steve.
-Let's talk about it,
though, because --
-Let's discuss.
-Yeah.
-Let's figure it out.
-So, boom, at first,
you liked Steve.
-Right. Yeah.
-You was into Steve.
-Yeah, I mean, Steve --
what a guy.
-Right. And then you just kind
of, like, dumped him.
-Oh, wow, it's getting real.
-No caution.
He didn't know
what was happening.
-Poor Steve.
-Y'all kept throwing the kids
on him to babysit.
He keeps saving y'all life.
All he's doing is
save y'all life.
-These are...
-He was beating everybody up.
-Yeah, saving your life,
and you're like,
"I'm moving on, dude."
-And you're like, "Oh, man,
I'm going to Jonathan.
Sorry."
-I do feel bad.
Honestly, I think the way
Jonathan and Nancy happened,
I was like --
She doesn't always make, like --
I don't know -- the most morally
right decisions all the time.
But that's human.
-Is she about to make
a decision --
-She's a hot girl.
-She is a hot girl. Yeah.
She is a hot girl.
[ Applause ]
Will we find out
this next season?
Do you know anything?
Have you read anything?
-Okay, wait, wait, wait,
'cause we didn't even get to
the juicy part.
-Right.
-Okay.
So, then, in this last season,
you was flirting with Steve.
So, like...what's it
really giving, Nancy?
-Yeah, Nancy.
Stancy.
-Stancy or Jancy?
-I feel like you
like Steve still.
-You know, you just
got to have options, I guess.
No, that's --
No, I'm just kidding.
-Yes! Nancy has options.
You heard it here today first.
Nancy has options.
-Also, Robin, by the way --
-Jonathan, you're out.
-Speaking of options.
-Well, you and Robin, from up to
the part that I'm up to,
you kind of really had a lot
together, screen time together.
It was kind of a ro-Nance
is what they're calling it.
-That's the word on the street.
Yeah, that's the name that --
-Do you miss Barb?
-[ Breathes deeply ]
-Oh, Barb!
Nice call! Yes! Thank you!
-Do you miss Barb?
-Can y'all write her back in?
-Wow!
-That's above my pay grade.
-Bring Barb back. Hashtag that.
-Oh, no.
-Yeah, what happened?
Nancy just kind of
forgot Barb.
-Yeah, she started
going with Jonathan.
Barb don't even matter no more.
-Do you think about Barb?
-Yeah, no, I think this is --
You know, this is kind of --
I never am allowed to
forget about Barb.
I get it.
You know,
it's part of Nancy's arc.
It definitely drives
her forward.
Has she completely dealt
with it?
I don't know.
But, yeah, we have not
forgotten about Barb for sure.
-I haven't. I miss Barb.
-Yeah, we love Barb.
-Barb tried to talk some
sense into Nancy.
-She did.
-She was a good friend.
-And y'all just let her go.
-People need to stop leaving.
I think that's the thing is,
they should just stick together.
It's when people go off by
themselves, you know --
-This is a lesson
to friends everywhere.
-Yeah.
-Do not be a third wheel,
because Demogorgons
will come get you.
-That's the lesson?
-That is the lesson.
-But, now, I don't want to know
what happens at the end of this,
but I kind of see
where it's going.
-What? Watch it.
-I'm taking my time with it.
I'm dipping it in ranch
and enjoying it.
-Mmm!
-Okay, I'll take that.
-That's what I call it
when I enjoy something.
I dip it in ranch.
-He likes mustard.
He doesn't like ranch.
-You don't like ranch?
-[ British accent ] No, I don't.
-She can't --
Nancy can't believe it.
Do you like ranch?
-She just had
a British accent again.
-She goes,
"You don't like ranch?
You don't like it?"
[ Normal voice ]
No, I'm not a fan.
Are you mustard?
Let me -- I have a talent.
-What is your favorite?
-I can guess.
I can guess what you are.
-Okay.
-Ketchup.
-Wait. So, ketchup or mustard?
This is ketchup or mustard.
That's the game I play.
-I feel like ketchup.
-Either/or. Okay.
-You tell us.
-Ready? I'm guessing.
-Oh, you are guessing.
-Sorry. It takes a lot of
mental energy.
No, don't say anything.
-Ketchup for sure.
Yeah.
-That's not the a game.
Wait, the game --
-I'm sorry. Do this.
Do another sauce. Okay.
-No, I don't do other sauces.
My talent is ketchup or mustard.
That's my talent.
Now I have to leave the party.
-That's such an easy game.
-That's not an easy game.
-Nobody likes mustard
like that but you.
-I do.
-She was obviously
going to say ketchup.
-Tariq's a mustard dude.
-I'm a mustard dude.
-Are you dipping
French fries in mustard?
-I mean, I would rather
mustard over ranch.
-Honey mustard.
Say "honey mustard."
-Gulden's -- brown, spicy.
-Yeah, Gulden's!
-Yes. Yes.
-Now, alright, wait.
Can we guess Questlove --
is he ketchup or mustard?
-Yes.
I already know this answer.
-Oh, I'm ketchup.
-Yeah. Yeah.
Alright, we're gonna say that.
-Anybody with taste
likes ketchup.
-What are you talking about?
Alright, how about -- Let's go
Kamal, Kamal.
Look at Kamal, alright?
Alright, Kamal's sitting there.
Yeah. Ketchup or mustard.
Ooh, that's interesting.
-We all know the answer.
-Really?
Alright. What are you saying?
Ketchup? What are you saying?
-Mustard vibes?
-You're getting
mustard vibes, right?
Oh! Mustard vibe!
See what happened?
Look at this.
-We don't even ask him.
-Spicy.
Add some spice to it.
Okay, yeah, put the
right adjective in front of
what kind of mustard it is.
-Alright, so,
at the end of this, though,
at the end of this season,
which I don't want to know,
Vecna is coming -- Vecna
is involved in everyone's life.
So you're probably not even
thinking about love triangle.
-Right.
-Yes, you are.
-I mean,
that's really how I feel.
You know,
everyone's Stancy, Jancy,
but I think, honestly,
she just probably needs
a little me time
after all of it, right?
-So much to think about.
Jonathan is boring.
-Like, they're still
in high school.
It's pretty intense.
-She's so smart.
She's so pretty.
She's got things to do.
-We love Nancy. Come on.
-Yes, we love Nancy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Natalia Dyer.
I want to show a clip.
Here's Natalia Dyer in Season 4
of "Stranger Things."
Take a look at this.
-♪ If I only could ♪
♪ I'd make a deal with God ♪
♪ And I'd get him
to swap our places ♪
♪ Be runnin' up that road ♪
♪ Be runnin' up that hill ♪
♪ Be runnin' up that buildin' ♪
♪♪
♪ And I'd get him
to swap our places ♪
♪ Be runnin' up that road ♪
♪ Be runnin' up that hill ♪
♪ Be runnin' up that buildin' ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Natalia Dyer, everybody.
Season 4 of "Stranger Things"
is streaming now on Netflix.
We'll be right back with a
performance from
Montell Fish, everybody.
Come on back.
-Whoo!